since my last video just under two weeks
ago the novel coronavirus outbreak has
continued to spread now infecting more
than a hundred thousand people worldwide
much scientific research is being
undertaken to try and understand the
transmission of the virus and in this
video we'll discuss some of the recent
evidence to try and explain why this
novel outbreak is spreading so fast so
to briefly recap from my last video in
2019 a new corona virus infecting humans
emerged in Wuhan China
the outside of the virus is decorated
with these spiked proteins and these spy
proteins are important for it to get
inside to hotels so what happens is the
spike proteins contain a receptor
binding domain and this can interact
with a human host cell preteen referred
to as a ste standing for angiotensin
converting enzyme T and so the spike
protein recognizes this and it enables
integration of the virus inside the cell
once inside the cell the virus can
replicate and cause further transmission
so if we can prevent this interaction
can we prevent transmission so this is
one of the major challenges that many
scientists are studying currently to try
and find ways to prevent transmission
because as created understanding
transmission of the virus is key to its
containment and future spreads and the
urgency of this is now heightening since
the number of people infected with this
novel outbreak is more than ten times
the number that were infected during the
2002 and 2003 infection so what we've
unfortunately witnessed is a rapid
spread of this novel coronavirus
outbreak but the key question is why why
is it spreading so fast and if we can
understand why it's spreading so fast
that's another potential target to
prevent transmission and so what we've
not learnt from the genome sequence of
the novel coronavirus is that the spike
protein differs from its close relatives
and what this means is the biochemistry
is different so this very recent
publication basically analyzed the
protein sequence of this novel
coronavirus glycoprotein the spy protein
are compared it to
closely related sequences or the other
coronaviruses and so what does paper
found is that the novel coronavirus
protein sequence for the spike protein
has a specific feeling like cleavage
site that's absent in other lineage B
coronaviruses so what does this actually
mean well what this means if we go back
to the spike protein a region of this
protein is a site that is recognized by
furin like proteins and what these
proteins do is they cut the protein and
so you can cut the spike protein into
different fragments and so I have a fear
in itself of urine like proteases are
now thought to cut the spike protein
which could further aids is activation
and integration into the cells and so
you already mentioned that the spy
protein recognizes a stew but it's now
thought that cleavage by fear enough
urine like proteins could also aids
entry into the cell and so what thought
this is important is really important to
understand because Furion is found in
lots of different human tissues
including the lungs liver and small
intestines which basically means the
virus is more likely to be able to
attack these different organs and it
could also explain some of the symptoms
that have been observed for people with
the corona virus such as liver failure
nonetheless more research is required to
fully understand the importance of these
pure and likely be sites and to try and
understand which parts of the virus life
cycle it's really important with and
this will better be able to help us
design effective strategies to prevent
transmission and so one way is to
potentially use pure and inhibitors and
this kind of goes back to what I said at
the end of the last video that if we
can't find a new vaccine to prevent
transmission it's more likely that we're
actually going to find something by
repurposing previously existing drugs
such as in the case of furin inhibitors
that are already around and modifying
those for the qurían of iris so the
presence of these cleavage sites then
might explain why the novel coronavirus
is spreading so fast because the
cleavers
it's also found in other viruses that
spread easily such as strains of the
influenza virus and say this is because
instead of the spiked proteins these
hemagglutinin proteins have furin like
cleavage sites however whilst this
research is really exciting we still
need to be cautious because we don't
know how important these fearing
cleavage sites are and what they do
require further testing and then were
unsure if these fuen inhibitors would
even work so we just have to be cautious
for now and note that you know there are
other viruses we've seen such just
explanatory pandemic and they didn't
have these fewer inactivation sites
however we've still got the ACE T
receptors that are potential targets as
well and interestingly it's also been
shown that the interaction between the
novel coronavirus bait spike protein and
ace 2 is 10 times stronger than it was
in the previous last virus so
essentially by blocking that interaction
we can prevent transmission so the
biochemistry it seems seems to be keyed
to the fast spread of this novel
coronavirus outbreak so as always thank
you for listening